we'll make this smooth segue to Rick
Sutcliffe ESPN Radio baseball analyst
and are you at Chicago pizza guy Rick I
am but you know let's make this quick
ya know because you guys talking about
pizzas got me hungry I need to I need
did you eat before you you would start a
game no I didn't you know Koufax and
Drysdale were the guys it said your body
it takes energy to burn whatever you put
in it so I tried to stay away from that
hey but I got to tell you man I'm really
I was going to call you tomorrow I'm
glad you called today this weekend I'm
headed over to Phoenix gonna play golf
with Gracie and then next weekend in the
San Diego helium and Bill Murray are
there we're going to play some golf and
then the following weeks and done well
that's they're going into the Hall of
Fame of the country me you know I just
thought of sudden you you work
year-round don't yes I do
but were you inviting me to play with
you or or was I was I was gonna and then
I realized after tonight I'm done
anything to do until spring training
again next year I forget I'm so sorry
man I was going to see if you were
available but I realized you're not so
Mark Grace one of my favorite people
your former teammate Bill Murray and
Brooks and Dunn and that's that's not a
bad it sounds like a TV show son not a
bad vacation is it yeah yeah but you
know what you sir
I'm rounding third I'm heading home and
feeling a little bit better but you know
what thank you're one of the first
people that I heard from and and you
stayed with me I appreciate that thank
you danos you know I've been there as
well my friend you know the thing that
we all hope and pray for is to get the
word treatable and we both got it so all
good all righty
how important is this game to the
Dodgers tonight if they don't advance
does anything happen yeah I mean aside
from they don't they don't advance but
you know are there changes there with
the Dodgers I mean they feels like its
World Series or bust
I totally agree
I mean I don't think anybody was more
favorite than them when you think about
the National League compared to the
American League the team record with 162
wins you go out there and and you lose
to a la carte team and I'm not taking
anything away from the Nationals what
David Martinez has done we know that
Strasburg out of the bullpen won the
wild-card game and relief we know what
he did by winning Game two
we saw the effort from Max Scherzer once
again in Game four we know that the
Walker Buehler is waiting on him I think
he gave up one hit yeah in Game one it's
not going to be easy I would heavily
favor Walker Buehler tonight as we
favored the Dodgers all year long but to
answer your point I I would say from top
to bottom there could be a lot of
changes in LA if they don't get past
this game tonight and then you're going
to be on the call for ESPN Radio
Cardinals in the Braves what does that
come down to in your opinion this has
been I mean this has been everything
that you could hope for as a fan as a
player particularly as a broadcaster
daño you thought you know in Game one it
was boring as it could possibly be till
like the eighth inning and then all of a
sudden all hell broke loose the bullpen
started giving it away back and forth
you know the tonight's a matchup of game
- what a pitcher's duel one - nothing
until a pinch-hit Homer I think in the
bottom of the 7th foltynewicz and flirty
you don't expect a lot of scoring
tonight it's just been everything but
one of the one of the coolest things
that I saw then with both before Game
four you know that the the you know
Wainwright was great in Game three but
you know the bullpen gave it up I was in
the clubhouse with boomer we're waiting
on you know the managers meetings and
all that and Adam Wainwright came in and
I shook his hand and I said hey
congratulations should Thanks
and Dakota Hudson came by who was
pitching that afternoon Game four and he
looked at Dakota and I could kind of
read his lips where he said get get us
to Game five and you can kind of see
Hudson nod his head like that the
coolest part of all was his Wayne
took off I thought he was going like
into the food room or whatever Danny
went into the weight room mm-hmm and and
just no one yeah you know exactly where
I'm going he he was setting a tone for
boys you know what we've been here
before
and you just go back you think about
2011 they were one strike away from
losing the World Series there are long
ways away from losing this series and I
I just like the tone that he set and
then of course you know it was Yadier
Molina once again coming up with a big
moment in October right move for the
Cubs to fire kill men I think the right
move for both Joe and the Cubs yeah yeah
I do
I I think that you know you look at the
way last year finished were they just
offensively just just look boring as
we've talked about before and then this
year I mean for the Cardinals to to come
to Wrigley at the end of the year and
sweep for one-run games
III just as Joe said I you know change
is good I guess him and deal had a good
night as they discussed that the mood
that they were going to make before the
season is it
I do i I I think I think it's a great
move for for both Joe particularly joke
because I could not be more fond of
anyone that I have um but I think it's
the right move for the Cubs to okay more
likely to be a standalone champion the
85 Bears or the 2016 Cubs oh my goodness
I mean the Bears dominated from you know
starts the beginning the thing I think
about you know these Vegas odds we have
now on how at one point to cut for an
eighty five percent chance to win and
then they were one with one percent
chance to win and then all of a sudden
they came back you know the 85 Bears I
mean the whole city of Chicago
celebrated that as you know but are we
more likely to get a bears champion or a
Cubs champion what happens sooner wow
man that's a great question
III guess I would hope for the Bears
because they've got the first shot at it
you know those guys you're going to see
a lot of changes before opening day next
year I believe obviously it starts with
the manager
but I think you're going to see a
personnel changes in the Cubs before
2020 starts Daniel did you ask to be
considered for the Cubs managerial job
window for me closed a long time ago I
know I got the opportunity you know I'm
a full-time grandpa man I got two of the
best grandkids on earth and I'm not
gonna let anything get in the way of
that do they know what you did for a
living yet no and I'll tell you my
favorite story about my six-year-old
grandson Ryder he was at this youth camp
that they have and he wore his Cubs hat
and this older kid that was like nine
looked at him he said I like the cup why
do you like the cups and my son-in-law
was right there he heard everything and
my grandson looked at him he said
because my grandpa used to play for the
Cubs if you could kind of see the older
kid looking like yeah right sure he did
whatever he goes what's your grandpa's
name and my grandson looked at him and
he said Gramps and I mean they just went
their own separate lanes so ya know he
has no idea that I'd love to keep it
that way when's the first time you met
Bill Murray first time I ever met him
was when Harry Caray had the stroke and
they brought bill in to do the game
along with Steve stone had celebrities
coming in and long story short Jody
Davis slid into home Eric Davis kicked
the pitcher out there brought in a
reliever throw well every fan there had
brought a TV in a radio so they could
hear bill well while the pitcher was
warming up Bill Murray bets Steve stone
a case of beer that I would steal second
on the second pitch Danno I slid in safe
to second base stone told him so said
you know Rick's got a bad hamstring he's
not as young as he once was he's never
attempted a stolen you know I told him
how dumb it was if they'll set that and
once I heard that bill had said that I
took off and as you know Ben has spent
the rest of the night down on rest I
remember going to a game the Cubs and
the Astros and Finley was playing
centerfield Luis Gonzales playing left
field and I remember
that you know we said to grace I used to
make fun and that he was so slow and I
said and so I'm killing him I'm you know
making fun of his lack of speed and
we're in left center and Gracie's on
first and he steals second base
and he grabs his crotch staring at us as
if to say here's your stolen base right
there oh my god the game within the game
within the game good stuff
hey have fun today and tell the boys
tell Gracie and Bill I said hello and
safe travels Thank You bud
that's a Rick Sutcliffe for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV stream for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]